welcome to this video playing fuga fuga
from belgium right yep I have to Bishop
c5 they have this this this is a weird
to beat we'd move order night XD Phi F
is really annoying it's a move order
directed against this Bishop c5 business
okay I'm switching back to something
like that also cannot be so bad it looks
a little bit like a classical Dutch here
I mean I'm not serving William so
probably haven't going to don't do well
with it but you'll see f4 it's probably
too too harsh so I get more need more
pieces I guess pushing at four levels it
was too too much but night to f7 first
is good aha he wants to trade queens
he's afraid I don't want to trade Queens
not going to play this this weird
opening and then trade queens and yeah
it's a good news though I have to take
it how to do this ok be seven is
unfortunately hanging and rugby AIDS is
a very lame move oh I it's a bit
difficult I'm not sure that I can
actually bother with covering this
okay you to get that f5 pawn
maybe nine th six cent and so on
I guess it will take me some I mean I
probably would do that
well I mean maybe the position is not so
bad if i can trade ok this one and
wanted to take this anyway and ok ok
let's let's keep that pawn down if he
takes a 5 out web f three teky five that
shouldn't be so bad only still going for
that song ok so he's got the bishops but
my structure is not that bad Madoff is
irritating a little bit but he can maybe
push my night away down ok probably
should form the f4 square
do you five as a move actually oh ok
that's surprising it doesn't want to
trade anyway I would assume ok want to
take know what you never know what kind
of idea there is we couldn't find
another reason why you would play a
Bishop to g5 auditory encourage the
capture ok can I get the Knight to f4
somehow whenever I move f6f 690 is
pushing is putting his knight on d5 this
is a bit awkward and maybe this we
should add 3 esta left 95
yeah it's a good move unfortunately i am
rook e8 was pretty pretty bad roocase 7
that's pretty no kiddin it's a bit
annoying i had to had to do that okay so
we had traded those
yeah and he starts to play good moose
now that's not fair
and I'd have six that I cannot take with
the bishop I cannot take with the rook
taking with the pawn is also sad man Wow
shoot not a bad game hmm the show page
six I cannot even take b7 unfortunately
Bishop f8 king of a droopy aid and he's
winning one of the pieces my bishops is
six oh my god what a what a bad game
it's not even doing that time morning so
this for be should be seven maybe
that's two losing i mean my position is
not improved I mean you could have one
pretty much immediately but it still
remains very bad
check
taking a c4 and rook so we had to take
check this is now probably probably
possible to hold check and yeah that I
can hold problem probably check I've
gotten the pawn back Ray check check
check check prolly offered draw offered
game drawn I enjoy playing with you I
didn't enjoy playing this game not
really ah i really wasn't it was it was
just it was just lost down there were a
couple of couple of moments i guess
where he could have could have killed me
yeah so around here yeah i probably have
to take thats objectively better and oh
he could have even done that that that
would have been a bit of a shocker whoa
check it's not that that I mean if you
see the idea as human player it's not so
easy to decide on that
it's two points yeah but hmm yeah f3r
ever seems to be okay what can also
always go back there now why this batch
better now this is what's well played
neither 54 strong and here I'm just in
trouble yeah yeah here um I had this d5
idea but i only saw that later and
assault at a point where I couldn't
really go for it anymore the thing is if
he takes I'm putting up something with
Nigeria bishop oops Bishop to d6 and
this is a bit a bit of a fortress I mean
the evaluation here it's not totally
clear to me but i think this seems
playable with night coming here or
possibly to have for the extra point is
not not felt much him yeah yeah i mean
probably have lost lost even more time
and this end game is really really bad
yeah yeah just jesus this is just losing
vicious t6 was was was decisive her
because i have exactly one check and
then this is lost yeah yeah I really not
playing better playing well here at the
moment I'm very lucky and very many
games Chen I'm still worse yeah but
somehow he he didn't manage to to pull
the trigger and and end the whole thing
in his favor okay well thanks for
watching